SAM DUTTON: We're standing in
front of the device wall here.
And yeah, we're going
to see how our app did.
Now we've been working on
building something for WebRTC.
Justin can tell you a
little bit about that.
And we're going to see
how the app performs
on a whole range of devices.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right.
So we just did a
talk about how AppRTC
is our sample app for WebRTC.
But it's trying to be a
really polished sample app
and trying to be
really, really fast.
And so Sam and I were just
talking about the device wall.
And we thought, hey,
what would happen
if we tried to fire
up 100 video chat
clients on every single
device we have here
on the device wall?
What would actually happen?
And it turned out to be,
actually, quite interesting.
When we fire it up, you can
see that these things all
come to life.
It's all pretty fast.
But some come to life
faster than others.
And you can also
see some variances
in terms of which ones
actually show a better frame
rate, a better camera feed.
And so being able to compare
the optics, the cameras,
of all these devices
side by side,
we've never even had
this ability before.
It's actually quite--
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
We're getting really
different-- like the color,
you're getting color
casts on this one.
Some of them are
sharper than others.
We've got a whole range.
Movement is-- some of
them are handling movement
much better than others.
And here we're saying the
classic user interface
problem, which is on
landscape telephones-- what
have we done here?
We've got the button is
halfway off the screen,
a really common problem
for user interface.
And, oh, here's another problem.
The Join button has gone tiny.
But in fact, the video
quality is great.
What really blows
me away is we've
got a stack of
different devices,
and WebRTC is working
really well on all of them.
Do you want to talk a bit about
the hardware and stuff that
does that?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
So internally, we're calling
down to the Android camera
API, which is doing
all this work for us.
And since every single
device is different,
we see different
performance coming
from these different devices.
But it's quite interesting
in that in the same lighting
conditions, everything
here is the same amount
light, same shutter and
everything like that.
SAM DUTTON: Check this one out.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah.
This one's super dark.
This one is really,
really jerky.
And then this one here is really
nice, a really good experience.
So it's just very interesting
just to see this visually.
Like all these specs
that people talk
about in cameras and
everything like that really
are displayed in terms of
what is the actual user
experience that you're
going to get out of it?
Well, here, you can
actually see it.
And Sam, you mentioned
the whole thing
about, what did we do
right on the app side
to make sure things are usable?
In some cases, we did
better than others.
But also, for the devices, like
how do these things actually
fare in a real world scenario?
What would the actual people
using these things actually
experience?
Well, you could actually see
this in a real world mode.
And I think it was
a great experiment.
SAM DUTTON: No, that's right.
What really interests me
is, we had a lot of talk
in the keynote today about
the next billion devices.
Well, a lot of those people
on the next billion devices,
in fact, they're coming onto
more affordable data plans.
And some of those
people are going
to be using video
on mobile devices.
And so you can see along
here what we really
need to be able to
do is do great video
and audio experience, but
with low CPU, low power usage,
and all the rest of it
that goes into making
it work well on a low-spec
device with limited bandwidth.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah,
I mean, you can just
think of a number of ways
that we could take this
in a further direction, though.
It would be really
interesting, just seeing--
doing this, what's the
actual power consumption
of every single device here.
And we got these great
scores for how fast is it
or some of the other things.
SAM DUTTON: Check this out.
This is-- I'm really
happy with that.
99, 99, 100.
JUSTIN UBERTI: But what if we
could also measure in power?
What is the actual
power usage of the site?
Or what is the FPS that we're
getting across each site?
I'm just like-- my mind's
going through a lot of cycles
now thinking about this
is a fantastic tool.
What else could we
actually do with this?
And I know that some
of the announcements
that were made this morning
about the actual cloud
laboratory for doing testing
on different devices,
I wonder if you could get
these same sorts of benchmarks?
And I know you mentioned
the next thing.
These are all calls in the
waiting state, where it's just
displaying it on local video
while it's waiting for the user
to join the call.
But then if we could have
some other way of connecting
these devices to some other
center of remote endpoint,
we could start seeing what is
the actual performance of them
when they go to
actually send that video
from the camera across the
network and that sort of thing.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
And one other thing, something
you said this morning
was that messaging apps
are becoming, really,
the dominant apps
on mobile devices.
And I think you said something
like 6 out of 10 of the most
popular apps on mobile--
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, yeah.
SAM DUTTON: --are now
apps that do messaging.
So it it's hugely
important, this.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, the
new Mary Meeker report
said the actual usage, the
top 10 apps in terms of usage,
six of them are just
pure communications apps.
There's other apps in there that
have some other functionality
and that are social networking
apps, but six of those apps
are actual communications.
And the point to
take away from this
is that the number
one thing that people
are doing on mobile
devices is communicating.
And I guess that's not
really that surprising
if you think about it.
They're phones, originally.
But still, we've gotten to
this thing of there's email,
and there's all
these other things.
First and foremost,
these devices
are being used
for communicating.
And so we've been out to
deliver great communications
experiences.
And this is a great way of
actually visualizing that.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
And that's something we
really need to do really well,
especially in these
conditions of low bandwidth
and low-spec devices.
And it's great to
see this stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]